Sheena Roscoe says it feels good to now
be part of the battle against climate
change
the 59-year-old Washington DC artist
known for her sewing designs and
eclectic style says she used to think
green energy was only for wealthy
homeowners I started seeing these things
on top of people roof
I was like them for the people who had
the houses it doesn't concern me because
I'm an apartment
Roscoe is enrolled in a city program for
low-income residents to receive
discounted electricity powered by solar
energy originally my bill would be a
hundred something it's down to 12
dollars
green power will come from these 4 000
solar panels installed atop an
underground water tank that holds
Municipal Water Bracken Hendricks is the
solar Project's lead developer all of
the energy flowing off of this project
is given away for free and that's going
to equal a reduction of energy bills
electricity bills for 500 families in
Washington DC
the project costs 5 million dollars
covered by investors and government
grants Hendricks says the system will
eventually pay for itself through the
sales of renewable energy credits to the
power company remaining profits will go
to a housing charity that co-owns the
project we're building clean energy
projects in community we're taking the
the wealth created by that energy
installation and we're making sure that
it's flowing back to the community
itself
all goes according to plan this yield
will generate green energy solar energy
for Washington D.C for the next two
decades this is a city that is a leader
in green energy using Renewables to meet
more than 60 percent of its energy needs
now the challenge is to have more of
this in more places every community and
every family can help to save the planet
and save money to boot Congress recently
passed climate legislation that includes
billions of dollars for clean energy
projects with a focus on disadvantaged
communities the goal is to cut U.S
carbon emissions by half by 2030. and
Roscoe says she's glad to have been
drafted I feel like I'm a part of
something
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington